>> Tucker: WON AN AMAZING
STORY, TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WELL, FOR MANY YEARS LEFT US
BILLIONAIRE GEORGE SOROS HAS
USED HIS WEALTH TO REMAKE OUR
SOCIETY.
AMERICAN SOCIETY.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE FROM TEXAS AND
PHILADELPHIA, THE STATE OF
VIRGINIA, HE HAS SPENT MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS BACK IN CANADA FOR
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY, THE
PROSECUTOR.
ONCE ELECTED, THEY HAVE TENDED
TO END CASH BAIL, TREATING
FELONIES LIKE MISDEMEANORS AND
SOMETIMES IGNORED CRIMES
ENTIRELY.
IN THE CITY OF PHILADELPHIA,
SOROS LACKED KRASNER COMING IN
THE MURDER RATE IS THE HIGHEST
THAT IT HAS BEEN IN A DECADE.
THE MAIN PARTY IS TO GET EVEN
SOFTER ON THE CRIME.
U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE EASTERN
DISTRICT JOINING US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
IT IS REMARKABLE IN A DEMOCRACY
THAT ONE MAN CAN HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REMAKE OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S WHAT
GEORGE SOROS IS DOING.
WHAT ARE HIS PRIORITIES?
WHAT ARE HIS GOALS AND DOING
THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL I WOULD SAY THAT
I THINK IN A LOT OF WAYS
PHILADELPHIA IS THE LABORATORY
FOR THIS EXPERIMENT.
AND SOROS FUNDED PROSECUTORS ARE
PLAYING OUT.
AND NOW THE RETURNS ARE IN TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT.
LARRY KRASNER HAS BEEN IN OFFICE
FOR ABOUT A YEAR AND HALF FUNDED
BY A MR. SOROS.
AND WE CAN LOOK AT THE DATA, AND
WE CAN SEE WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
PHILADELPHIA.
AND AS YOU SAID, HOMICIDES HAVE
SKYROCKETED.
SHOOTINGS HAVE SKYROCKETED.
THE WORST CRIMES OF VIOLENT
CRIME HAVE REALLY GONE UP.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, SOME OF THE
LOW LEVEL AND THE MID-LEVEL
CRIMES HAVE ALSO GONE UP.
BUT THEY AREN'T BEING REPORTED.
AND THE REASON THAT THEY ARE NOT
BEING REPORTED IS BECAUSE THE
D.A. HAS SAID HE IS NOT GOING TO
PROSECUTE THEM.
SO YOU HAVE STATISTICALLY A BAD
SITUATION THAT HAS DEVELOPED IN
PHILADELPHIA, BUT ACTUALLY THE
REALITY ON THE GROUND IS EVEN
WORSE THAN THE STATISTICS.
AND WHAT MR. SOROS WANTS TO DO
IS THAT HE WANTS TO IMPLEMENT
HIS RADICAL AGENDA, AND HE
REALIZES THAT HE CAN'T DO THAT
TO THE NORMAL DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS.
NORMALLY IF YOU'RE GOING TO TRY
TO GET CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM,
YOU HAVE TO DO IT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE.
YOU HAVE TO GET BROAD PUBLIC
SUPPORT FOR THE CHANGES THAT YOU
WANT TO INSTITUTE.
HE IS TAKING WHAT I WOULD
DESCRIBE AS AN ILLEGITIMATE
ANTI-DEMOCRATIC BY TRYING TO
PURCHASE D.A. ELECTIONS, AND
ONCE THE D.A. IS IN PLACE, HE OR
SHE DOES NOT ENFORCE THE LAW.
AND PRESTO, YOU HAVE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM.
>> Tucker: EVERYTHING YOU SAID
IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, AND FOR
THOSE WORRIED ABOUT THE
HIJACKING OF OUR DEMOCRACY, HERE
IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF ACTUALLY
HAPPENING.
BUT QUICKLY, I'M JUST WONDERING
WHO IS THE WINNER IN THIS?
OF VIOLENT CRIME GOES UP MORE
PEOPLE ARE MURDERED, WHY WOULD
YOU WANT SO-CALLED REFORM OF
THIS KIND?
>> I THINK THAT THE WINNERS IN
THE STORY ARE DEFENDANTS.
UNFORTUNATELY, CRIMINALS ARE THE
WINNERS IN THE STORY.
AND MR. KRASNER MAKES NO BONES
ABOUT THAT.
HE IS NOT EVEN PRETENDING TO BE
A PROSECUTOR.
HE CALLS HIMSELF A PUBLIC
DEFENDER WITH POWER.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE LETTING THE FOX
IN THE HEN HOUSE.
ONCE HE IS IN, HE IS TRYING TO
CAUSE AS MUCH HAVOC AS POSSIBLE.
HE HAS NO BACKGROUND AS
PROSECUTOR.
HE HAS NO INTEREST IN
PROSECUTION.
HE HAS AN INTEREST IN CRAMMING
DOWN HIS A RADICAL PRO-DEFENDANT
IDEOLOGY ON EVERYONE ELSE.
>> Tucker: THE EFFECTS ARE
JUST HORRIFYING.
HORRIFYING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK THAT PEOPLE DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT GEORGE SOROS IS
MAKING THIS COUNTRY AND THEY
SHOULD UNDERSTAND.
>> I'M GLAD THAT YOU ARE RAISING
AWARENESS ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: THANKS VERY MUCH.
WE ARE TRYING.
AND SOROS HAS EFFECTIVELY
INTIMIDATED PEOPLE TO NOT
CRITICIZING HIM.
SOME MORAL CRIME TO CALLED US TO